my name is Rachel Sarnoff I am a fourth
year medical student at NYU Langone
Medical School in full disclosure I am
one of your teachers we've done each
other for a while and so I'm interested
in what you're interested in which is
what which is the microbiome as it
connects to human health
what's the microbiome the microbiome is
the collection of all of the
microorganisms that are part of the
human body that are not our own cells
and there are trillions of them right
yeah trillions over 99% of the DNA that
is composed in the human body is not our
own it's actually it belongs to bacteria
fungi archaea other which is amazing
right so why is that interesting in
terms of say diseases
well I'm especially interested in a link
that we're finding between the
microbiome and colon cancer what's that
link so that link is inspired in part by
the rise in colon cancer in young people
we're seeing a rise in colon cancer in
people under the age of 50 years old
which is really scary and it has
inspired a lot of scientists to try to
look for any potential ideologies that
we might not already understand when it
comes to colon cancer all right so there
are trillions of bacteria maybe one to
two thousand maybe more different
species I think many of them just alone
could kill you but there's a war of the
world going on they keep themselves in
check so what are we finding in terms of
certain species of bacteria are they
somehow linked to an increased risk of
colon cancer or colon polyps what have
you found in your reading and then in
your research yeah so in the literature
there have been links that have been
made between certain bacteria and colon
cancer what hasn't been looked at is the
polyp stage which is before it turns
into a full colon cancer is there
anything that we can conclude about the
micro environment of the colon and colon
polyp production something that would
predispose to getting polyps that could
then in the future turn into cancer and
what's the research show so far I
actually work in the in dr. bleezers
microbiome lab doc
Martin Blaser over at the VA here at NYU
and one p.i their name Giulio cuarta and
I have been looking at colonoscopies and
he has noticed in his training that when
he does a colonoscopy oftentimes he sees
clusters of polyps in in the colons that
he's he's scoping and that has kind of
peeked an idea in his mind where is
there something about the micro
environment of this area of the colon
that is Paulo producing so what we did
was we recruited a cohort of people
cohort meaning a bunch of people a bunch
of people at the VA and at Bellevue and
they were presenting for routine
colonoscopy and after informed consent
we essentially took aspirins which are
basically little tubes of fluid from
their colonoscopy and we looked at the
microbiome from those aspirates and then
we essentially looked at the microbiome
and whether they made polyps or not and
looked at any significant differences
that would you find out so what we found
out is that very specific groups of
bacteria were more abundant in patients
who had polyps than patients who did not
so its jacooz yeah those are the ones
that maybe are somehow doing something
that increases the risk of colon polyps
which could increase the risk of colon
cancer correct
okay now you piqued my interest so then
what do you do so then what we did was
we said what do all of these groups of
bacteria have in common
is there something they have in common
and we realized that nearly all of the
groups produce this one molecule which
is called butyrate butyrate is a fatty
acid it's a volatile compound that's
produced by bacteria and volatile
meaning it kind of can go up into the
air yes it turns in it it's a gas yeah
exactly
so and do we know anything about whether
butyrate can cause colon polyps well
there's actually a study from 2014 by a
group that that was published in cell
where they found that in mice that have
a few different mutations if they give
butyrate to them in their colon they
produce
polyps so does that mean that maybe
someday you can just blow into a box or
into a bag or into a balloon and measure
butyrate and say ah you're predisposed
to colon polyps or am I going too far
into the future um I wouldn't say that's
far off from what could possibly happen
so this is you know you're seeing sort
of research this is way before it's out
there and in the in practice but this is
the kind of stuff that's going on in and
it's kind of really interesting and the
microbiome which were also interested in
and it all kind of makes sense right I
mean the reason why you're looking at
bacteria in the colon what does that
have to do with colon cancer is that you
have these trillions of bacteria they're
doing stuff and we're seeing at the same
time we're seeing that colon cancer is
becoming more common in people who are
young and you have to think well gee
maybe we're somehow changing our
microbiome by antibiotics by diet or by
something else that we don't even know
yeah absolutely
butyrate is actually one of the products
when you eat fiber bacteria turn it into
a bunch of molecules one of them is
butyrate so it actually is very much
connected to diet so the thought is hmm
if there's something that we're doing to
change our microbiome how do we figure
out which people are having their
microbiome change in such a way that
predisposes them to call it polyps in
colon cancer it's so exciting and we're
finding more and more more broadly in
terms of microbiome research that the
microbiome is involved in so many
different disease processes especially
correlations between microbiome changes
and a lot of chronic diseases not only
certain colon cancer like what what
other diseases well it's it's known that
certain microbiomes young in life
especially in patients who've had early
life antibiotics are correlated with an
increased risk of asthma and type 2
diabetes and other chronic
non-communicable diseases once again
spread from one to another yes of of the
Western world and it's interesting we're
also finding out that there is a gut
mind connection yes that changes in the
gut can actually be
tected in the brain and the other way
around the changes in the brain can be
detected in the gut so we're at the
beginning of a very exciting new field
of research which actually been going on
for a while but now it's really heating
up isn't it yes exactly
it's very exciting I love this work it
seems to be at the forefront of our
understanding of especially chronic
disease